so you stumbled upon or heard about a
thing called SCP and you're wondering
what it's all about this guide has all
the information you need to know about
what the SCP foundation is and what it
has to want for you think of it as the
ultimate primer to the universe and the
wiki as it is and should be seen today
this guide is split up into three
sections and they are as follows
number one the basics an introduction to
the SCP foundation and wiki covering the
SCP format object classes in universe
lore about the foundation and important
vocabulary and why it all matters number
two in universe elements this covers
some background information and a lot of
commonly used terms that might leave a
new reader lost or confused number 3
things to read and do a tour of the
entire SCP universe covering all modes
of writing and different kinds of pieces
that you can read from - J's to exs 0 0
1 proposals to groups of interest tales
and canons there's a lot more than just
the SCP series ok let's get started the
basics operating clandestine and
worldwide the foundation operates beyond
jurisdiction empowered and entrusted by
every major national government with the
containing anomalous objects entities
and phenomena these anomalies pose a
significant threat to global security by
threatening either physical or
psychological harm introduction the SCP
foundation is a collaborative writing
platform centering around a fictional
foundation a scientific and military
organization that seeks to protect
humanity and the status quo by locating
and containing anomalies objects life
forms events locations concepts
creations and phenomena that in one way
or another violate natural law on the
SCP wiki authors tell stories and
explore ideas within this urban fantasy
science fiction universe creating rich
pieces of writing that take place in a
world where the anomalous exists and how
people and organizations interact with
them these articles may showcase the
different types of phenomena that might
exist in this universe the SCP is
themselves or tell compelling narratives
about life and interactions within the
SCP world tales canons and groups of
interest formats the central focus of
the SCP wiki is the SCP file commonly
referred to as just an SCP it is a set
of in universe technical documentation
supposedly compiled by the foundation in
an effort to understand analyze
experiment with and most importantly
contain the anomaly the SCP file is in
effect a form of constrained writing an
immersive way to tell story about the
nature and history of an anomalous
object or entity whether it directly or
by hinting at some greater idea
each SCP is given a unique serial number
or designation and on the wiki you can
browse scps with designations ranging
from one to three thousand nine hundred
and ninety nine they are organized into
four numerical series series 1a C p1
through the 999 series one was written
from 2007 to 2011
series two scp-1000 through two SCP 1999
series two was written from 2011 to 2013
series 3 scp-2000 through two SCP 2999
series three was written from 2013 to
2017 and series four SCP 3003 to SCP
3999 this series is still being written
but it started in 2017 the SCP format an
SCP file has a very specific format that
in general must be strictly adhered to
as cps are the backbone of the entire
franchise these documents are the set
pieces of the universe showcasing its
tone stories and possibilities the basic
format of an SCP is as follows
item number SCP - than the number object
class then a category name special
containment procedures then a detailed
summary of all specific means needed to
make sure the anomaly is safely
contained description then a technically
written documentation of all things that
the anomaly is does and can't do and
finally supplements optional additional
files added onto the base document each
SCP is given an object class based on
the degree of containment difficulty
here are the primary object classes
safe the anomaly can be contained by
simply leaving it alone
no special procedures methods or events
are necessary to keep it from damaging
the world this does not necessarily mean
it's not dangerous a safe class object
can be world-threatening if not
contained but it's just really easy to
contain them some notable examples of
safe class SCPs are scp-1981 SCP 2579
scp-993 SCP 1425 and SCP 30 39 all
examples will be in the video
description
next euclid the anomaly is inherently
unpredictable or requires some amount of
special effort to be contained you're
not quite sure what will happen if you
leave it alone and it might be a little
bit more complex than a safe class
entity object or phenomenon some notable
examples of euclid class SCPs
are SCP 3008 SCP 4:26 SCP 1171 SCP 3001
and scp-1609 and finally Keter these
SCPs are really difficult to contain
requiring a huge expenditure of
resources or extensively complex
containment procedures the most
dangerous of phenomena are classed as
Keter often but not always posing an
existential threat to humanity the world
or universal structure itself some
notable examples of Keter class SCP Tsar
scp-1730 9 ASAP 231 scp-2932 p20 293 an
SCP 3200
in addition there are a number of
esoteric and secondary classes that are
used much less than the big three that I
just mentioned but still serve important
purposes foul meal this is a very rare
object class only known to the highest
levels of the foundation in essence the
meal class objects are anti Keter they
are used in the containment or
counteracting of other SCPs they act as
powerful tools to be used by the
foundation which normally rarely uses
anomalies some notable examples of
thymio classes EPS are scp-2000 SCP
2003's AP 3000 SCP 179 and SCP 30 31 and
finally neutralized it used to be
anomalous now it's not maybe it just
stopped working on its own maybe someone
accidentally or purposefully destroyed
it either way it no longer has
functional anomalous properties some
notable examples of neutralized class
SCPs
are scp-1472 682 SCP 35:19 SCP 1762 and
SCP 2420 if you want to stop watching
this guide now and start diving into the
wiki this is a good time to do so but be
sure to finish this guide if you're
unsure of anything maybe you can pick
one from the links from the description
and then follow the cross links and
navigation in the article maybe you can
go to a series page I highly recommend
series 2 & 3 and just click on one with
an intriguing title or you could roll
the dice and press random SCP one of the
best ways to learn about the foundation
is to discover for yourself all the
genres emotions and ideas it can evoke
to keep that sense of mystery and gritty
realism
there's still a lot to learn about the
culture and vocabulary and universe of
the site you can find out and learn by
yourself just by reading as much as you
can
playing it by ear that's pretty fun that
way or if you'd like to get a better
handle on everything that's going on and
a few more ways to drop you into the
community stay tuned I still have a lot
to show you next up in universe elements
foundations structure and protocol
security clearance represents how much
information about an object you're
allowed to know if you've read through
an SCP or to your band to have seen
these that I expunged redacted or the
text completely blacked out these
keywords are common hallmarks and tools
of narrative of the SCP wiki signifying
that the information has been classified
to a higher clearance or has been
cleansed completely it adds an element
of horror through absence that is
classic to the SCP fandom for a great
example of how security clearance levels
can be used read SCP 23:17 there are
also many types of workers in the
foundation among them we have
containment specialists researchers and
security tactical response officers
there are field agents who are out in
the world
undercover looking for signs of
anomalous activity and mobile task
forces special units that are assigned
to carry out certain dangerous jobs the
task force's document contains a list of
mobile task forces along with their
associated scps the foundation is
usually thought of as a far-reaching
organization and so their bases are
found across the globe and sometimes
outside of it these bases can be sites
or areas for more information read
secure facilities locations the leaders
of individual areas or sites are
high-ranking level for researchers known
as site directors there are few in the
foundation that rank higher that site
director and they are the own five
Council the ultimate leaders of the
entire foundation
the overseer counsel abbreviated 205 is
a group of 13 people who manage all
foundation operations worldwide and have
complete access to all information
redacted or not their identities are
classified for safety and they are only
referred to by their ID l5 1 through 13
in addition some versions of Canon also
include the existence of an
administrator the creator of the
foundation finally one of the most
interesting parts of the foundation are
d-class personnel or Class DS a cannon
around d-class personnel helps showcase
the colder and more morally grey side of
the foundation in order to experiment
with and contain scps the foundation
needs lab rats to test things with the
d-class oftentimes they are recruited
from death row or the prison population
serving as expendable personnel that are
used to handle hazardous anomalies in
the early days of the site a common
headcanon was that all d-class were
executed at the end of the month however
this idea has gone out of fashion as the
site has evolved for more interesting
stories about Class D personnel try
reading entries from the d-class contest
terms to know the SCP wiki has created a
wide set of terminology and new
innovations inventing concepts that are
unique to the premise of the site and
found nearly no more else in literature
you may want to know these terms before
you dive in anomalous classifications
mimetic or mean a meme is any unit of
information that can spread and transfer
itself throughout society mimetic
effects deal with how the brain
understands and reacts to media it is a
piece of data in the subjects mind that
has an anomalous effect on that subjects
physical or mental state that is spread
when someone else becomes aware of the
same information in particular anomalous
mimetic agents are bits of hazardous
information that are like mental virus
triggering anomalous reactions in people
who are exposed to them
anteye mimetic or anti meme an anti meme
is the opposite of a mean it has self
censoring properties anomalous anti
memes are perfectly mentally camouflaged
whether by making you unable to hold
your perception of one in your
short-term memory or making you unable
to comprehend the concept of its
existence Cognito hazard a Cognito
hazard is something that is dangerous
when we perceive it with one of the five
senses for example a sound that causes
you to bleed from every pore or a smell
that causes you to go insane all mimetic
effects are a subset of Cognito hazards
as in order to process the information
you have to sense it info hazard info
hazards are anomalous effects that
trigger when the SCP is described
referred to or acknowledged you don't
even have to sense the thing to be
affected by an info hazard you just have
to know that it exists it affects data
written about the anomaly and people
that are made aware of the existence of
the effect
Anto kinetic or reality vendor an auto
kinetic being can manipulate the laws of
reality magic through anomalous means
groups of interests contain and study
reality vendors often in unethical ways
creating some moral crises for the
foundation an art or an artist an art is
short for anomalous art many people and
groups aware of the existence of reality
breaking phenomena choose to explore it
by creating often surrealist art with
Xtranormal properties these people being
called and artists
[Music]
narrative ik or paid a physical a
narrative accan amelie manifests itself
within works of fiction often affecting
the content of the work involved by
creating characters changing the setting
or blurring the line between fiction and
the reality the pay de Fora calor paid a
physical SCP explores narrative accan
amélie's using the wiki itself as the
narrative it explores the idea of
characters we write on the website
attempting to communicate and manipulate
us and being aware of things on the
website like author pages deletions and
discussion forms technology and
engineering scranton reality anchor
Scranton reality anchors our
technological devices used by the
foundation to essentially regulate
consensus reality they cancel out or
prevent the effects of reality bending
entities and anchored down areas where
the level of unreality is higher or
lower than normal counter bending it so
that it matches the reality that we know
and inhabit many contemporary authors
have criticized the widespread use of
SRA S as a catch-all for containing any
type of structural or Anto kinetic
effect
tella kill yes RA
back in the old days except the problem
was worse in its original form it was a
metal that blocked all mind affecting or
compulsive effects people went crazy
over it it started using it in all their
containment procedures a mistakenly
thought it also blocked mimetic effects
Scranton's rewrite of the article added
some nuances and drawbacks to it and its
usage had fallen by the wayside anyway
as people have became more innovative
with writing
hume's a unit of measurement that
measures the intensity of reality
present in an area crucial to
understanding how sra s and other
technologies work they are useful in
quantifying how powerful reality bending
effects are relative to each other
k class scenario a term used to classify
possible apocalypse scenarios which the
foundation deals with on a daily basis
when discussing the possible outcomes of
dangerous effects or entities the most
common type is XK class which describes
a conventional destruction of the planet
scenario there are multiple minor ones
whose exact definitions that Canon are
being argued over including seek a class
the restructuring of a reality ake a
class humanity goes crazy SK class the
dominant species on earth is no longer
humans and Z K class reality universal
failure amnestic Mindwipe drugs a
narrative tool used by authors to
explain a how the foundation is able to
keep the masquerade of secrecy and be to
create stories dealing with memory and
knowledge in universe these are simply
chemicals that arrays a normal humans
memory of some amount of time when the
foundation has to recover an anomaly in
the real world or seriously messes up
these are used
things to read and do there's more to
the wiki than the SCP series in this
section I open the door to the other
areas of the site that are part of the
foundation universe as well as answer
some common questions about key but
confusing parts of the site what is SCP
1 in the early days of the site when the
wiki was just getting started there was
some debate over what should be this
sacred number 1 everyone agreed that it
had to be incredibly written everyone
agreed that it had to be big
something deserving of the very first
spot but nobody could agree who should
do the honor of writing it the answer
everyone can write their own vision of
SCP one
of proposals an author's individual idea
of number one they vary wildly and
contradict each other on the number one
hub page it says that the quote real
number 1 is so secret that a number of
false ones have been created this
explanation allows there to be multiple
self-contradictory number ones one of
them could be the true one to you or
maybe you want a couple to be canonical
at the same time maybe all of them are
fake maybe all of them are true
it all depends on your cannon and how
much you like a given proposal in effect
SCP one proposal tsar cannon builders
each one sets the tone for a particular
author's vision of the foundation itself
creating an SCP one proposal is as easy
as writing and then submitting it just
like any other SCP although unless
you're incredibly experienced it will
most likely get rejected by the
community and deleted as of November
2017 nineteen SCP one proposal have been
successfully posted each one is the
product of a lot of work and a high
concept here are six of the 1944 the
rapture or apocalypse SCP one is the
angel guarding Eden number two dr.
Mann's proposal the first and only
natural anomaly was a spiral path in New
York a group of ambitious scientists
experimented with reality using this as
the thread and created every single
other anomaly in the database number 3s
Andrew swans proposal the SCP foundation
is aware of its fiction ality they are
currently discussing ways to kill their
authors number four Roget's proposal
header class anomalies are an inherent
part of the universe and can be
contained using each other by releasing
all Keter class anomalies the universe
can be manually restructured number five
twisted gears cactus proposal SCP one is
one manifestation of the mechanical God
worshipped by a clockwork cult which
wreaked havoc on the world before the
military destroyed it
and finally number six calledand
proposal humanity was originally a slave
race whose suffering was harvested to
create utopia on another planet we
escaped and then tried to cloak
ourselves the cloak failed and our
masters are trying to bring us home it's
my personal suggestion that you don't
start with SCP one the proposals are
usually quite complex and requires some
knowledge of foundation lore which is
either played with expanded on or
subverted read conventional SCPs before
you take the number one deep dive
[Music]
special classifications
- e^x - j + - AR c there are other types
of documents that use the basic SCP
format and style but utilized in a
different way this allows different
stories with more diverse tones and
themes to be told the SCP X
classification designates an SCP that is
no longer considered anomalous it is
explained the object or phenomenon in
question still exists but the foundation
has deemed it to be an acceptable part
of consensus reality or it was a giant
fake out or it turned out to be just a
new scientific discovery an SCP - J is a
joke SCP a parody SCP in a sense joke SC
peas are explicitly non-canon using the
SCP format to joke around or make fun of
something for the benefit of the reader
they may riff on in universe tropes like
overwrought security over-the-top
containment cold posting or bad original
characters or they may parody things
like food poisoning bad drivers easily
angered people or that one movie they
may even make fun of the elements in the
other popular SCP cannons
ultimately a joke SCP is just a way to
make the reader laugh if the joke SCP is
not well-written and very funny it'll be
down voted and finally we have SCP a RC
archived SCPs these are usually legacy
pages from the very old days of the site
when standards were low and the mass
edit had not been conducted yet while
most of these SCPs were deleted some of
them needed to have text archives due to
their usage and other tales are still
existing as cps or because they were
historically important they are seeing
is no longer in use since the opening of
series 2 3 & 4 and you will most likely
never need to read one of these tales
canons and collaborative logs tales are
how the foundation universe gets
deepened and extended beyond the limits
of the simple SCP file it allows authors
to tell stories where groups or people
can interact with each other in the SCP
universe to expand on ideas already
created in SE PS or just you know to
write a prose some authors may also turn
their tales into a series usually if
they have a cohesive idea in mind or if
it gets really popular
notable series include there is no anti
mimetics division the cool war the
Lombardy tales tales of mister collector
and pitch haven you can find tales in
the top rated tales tales archive as
submissions to a themed contest or by
trawling around and finding
recommendations you can also as well
soon learn read the tales in a cannon a
cannon is your own set of assumptions
about the tone setting and dynamic of
the universe each of the cannons in the
cannon hub is a wildly different set of
assumptions based off the baseline SCP
foundation think of them as mega tale
hubs or parallel universes or
self-contained cinematic universes for
authors to plan here are five notable
cannon
broken masquerade a world where the
foundation's existence is known by
everyone resurrection a deliberate
attempt to resurrect the action
orientated SCP dr. crazy days of series
one in which an MTF composed of
anomalous humans is formed third law a
pulpy sci-fi para tech world dominated
by the machinations of Prometheus Labs
and Andersen robotics rat's nest the
military killed God and the foundation
is covering it up reality is slowly
unraveling and falling apart the Gulf
small-scale poignant series set in the
southern United States usually having a
restful mysterious feel and featuring
religious symbolism and unconventional
types of media a number of pages on the
site are tagged as collaborative
collaborative logs or pages can be
edited and added to by anyone although
some quality oversight still exists this
is a good way to get your creative chops
and contribute whilst not taking the
plunge of writing an SCP the three main
collaborative pages exist as lists of
mini scps
very small scale items or phenomena that
don't need to have a narrative but still
need to be unique appropriate and
interesting they are log of anomalous
items the SCP foundation has discovered
a substantial number of items which are
simply too useless to merit further
attention this document lists those
items which have prompted some curiosity
log of extra-normal events this page is
to document anomalous events that have
attracted the Foundation's interests but
occurred too briefly for the foundation
to secure or contain them and finally
log of unexplained locations this page
is to be devoted to the documentation of
low threat anomalous locations which
have been discovered by the SCP
foundation over
years there are a number of other
collaborative pages usually SCP
supplements or logs keep in mind that
guidelines for contributions still apply
though and if your addition is deemed to
be below standard it'll probably be
removed groups of interest the
foundation isn't the only fish in the
anomalous sea other organizations
collective and groups exist that utilize
or create paranormal phenomena for their
own purposes some are associates of the
foundation others are rivals to it many
of them quietly pursue their own
interests while a great many of them
fall on the lines of good and/or evil
the vast majority simply have a goal in
mind that somewhere in between here are
seven notable groups of interest are we
cool yet a collection of an artist's
usually producing surreal and disturbing
works of art their pieces are designed
to have maximum impact and are usually
lethal in some way the chaos insurgency
a rogue cell of the foundation that uses
terrorist means to steal and repurpose
powerful anomalies to gain control over
nations and conduct unethical
experiments using them the Church of the
broken God a widespread cult believing
in a clockwork God who is broken into
pieces all over the world
dr. Wonder tainment an individual or
company that makes anomalous artifacts
that are supposed to be children's toys
[Music]
the Serpent's hand a small organization
headquartered in an interdimensional
library believing in anomalous rights
and the normalization of the paranormal
and magical Marshall Carter and dark a
corporation that buys and sells
anomalous items for the benefit of the
super-rich global occult coalition or
the GOC a massive military organization
under control of the UN using technology
and force to destroy the Xtranormal
wherever they find it many groups also
have their own form of documentation
similar to an SCP on the wiki they are
called GOI formats and they are stories
told from a different perspective in the
foundation for more information visit
the groups of interest page as well as
the ongoing groups of interest overview
and guide on SCP Declassified subreddit
beyond the main site you can find
stories and SCPs to read even beyond the
classifications and places i've already
detailed in this final section i present
other outlets of writing associated or
tied to the SCP wiki that you can also
look into firstly a great place for you
to discover lesser-known but very
well-written tales and scps are in the
contest archive for example scp-1000
2,000 and 3,000 contests all have SCPs
themed around urban legends sci-fi and
horror respectively you have the short
works contest and the d-class contest
mentioned earlier and the history
contest for both tails and scps then
there are the gigantic multi-part mobile
task force contests and groups of
interest contests and then the dystopia
and reimagining contests and so forth
there's so much to find The Wanderers
library is set in the mysterious ancient
magical library of the Serpent's hand
it includes prose pieces and poetry set
in the SCP universe but focused on a
voguing a sense of wonder of the
extraordinary and fantastical quote a
sense that there is a larger world
beyond the one we know in the world of
the library these wonders are hidden but
never truly far away but never forget
that this is a Wilder world than our own
and it's never entirely safe either and
finally we have the international
foreign SCP branches there's French SCPs
Russian SCPs Japanese SCPs and a whole
bunch more each brand has their own set
of SCPs
many of which have extremely creative
and diverse ideas if you're looking for
more SCPs to read this might be a place
to find cool concepts and if you don't
know a foreign language the main SCP int
wiki hub has translations of some of
them this was entirely written by reddit
user module 'm 83 over on the SCP
Declassified subreddit all links will be
in the description if you enjoyed it
you have modulo 83 some praise in the
comment section for writing something I
couldn't write myself I hope it answered
most of your questions about who we are
and what we do and that it convinced you
to take a dive and become part of the
universe and the community
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bishop Desmond Hoskins and gets
a very thank you all very much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
you